all right speaking of Congress Congress
just voted on a bipartisan basis for a
defense bill that includes the
reauthorization of something called
section 702 you might have heard us talk
about it of the foreign intelligence
surveillance act otherwise known as fisa
now the stated goal of the program
sounds fine it allows us Intel agencies
to collect online Communications from
nonameric citizens outside the United
States without a warrant but what has it
has become come is something much more
nefarious all week we've seen members of
the DC unip party working overtime to
defend the program and in doing so
defending the program's many
abuses 702 is a foreign uh intelligent
surveillance act that's why the f is in
foreign there's just a lot of U um myths
and conspiracy theories and uh incorrect
narratives I've called it the the most
important law that most Americans have
never heard of before um and as I said
there just seems to be a lot of
confusion yeah no we're not dumb Senator
there's no confusion here the angle
knows exactly what's going on Section
702 was used to Target Americans during
the George Floyd and January 6th riots
another example in June of 2022 an FBI
analyst conducted overly broad searches
for information about a US senator and a
state senator in the section 702
database in October of this year an FBI
specialist ran a search using the social
security number of a state judge who had
complained to the FBI about alleged
civil rights violations perpetrated by a
municipal chief of police so in fact
these practices are so widespread that a
2022 report by a d by the dni disclosed
that the FBI conducted as many as
3.4 million warrantless searches of us
data that had been previously collected
by the NSA now the American public
deserves far better than to have their
own Representatives pass a bill that
allows their government that they pay
for to vacuum up their information so
shame on Congress hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else